yes people are discontented with the bad
storytelling but it doesn't necessarily
mean that if you give them good stories
they're going to live good lives the
proof in the pudding is that if you
listen to all these people people like
the critical Drinker and and his ilk
that have been uh critiquing the the new
Lord of the Rings series even before
they've managed to see it uh their
reference point where their relationship
with with the show is almost one of
religious awe
um they they
for them the experience of the story has
has become a Akin to
a religious experience and so when it's
wrong they react to it not as frustrated
artists
but as people who walked into a
heretical church right and I'm saying
this not to not to make fun of them
um I I understand what's going on I
think and it's uh it's it's a function
of where we are in this civilization
it's a function of the decadence of of
Western Christendom in the level that it
is
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so hello everyone I'm really excited to
be back with Nicholas kotar for those
who follow the channel you've seen him a
few times on uh having discussions about
all kinds of things he is a writer
himself he just published a novella
called the son of the deathless in his
Raven Sun series but we're also going to
talk about this particular cultural
moment of what kind of stories we can
tell
in the strange times that we are living
so Nicholas first of all congratulations
on the new book
thank you it's uh
the the pandemic killed storytelling for
me or at least the active storytelling
uh so this is the first thing I've
written in first long thing I've written
almost two years yeah well they you know
the idea of people seem to think that
they said you know you're locked in your
house you know you're you know this is a
good time to to do but it's not always
because it was there was such an
impressive
we're in such an impressive State it's
not easy to get those creative juices
flowing let's say no I mean creative
juices don't come out of a vacuum they
come out of out of a uh a craft a ritual
and when when the ritual is destroyed
because everything about your life is no
longer ritualized and it's you're stuck
in this massive
I mean it's it's the Doom right it's
just around you all the time and you
can't hide from it and that's that's not
conducive so no yeah it didn't help
and so
um yeah tell us first of all baby tell
us a little bit about what the what the
the premise of the this new Novella is
and then we'll move into our Strange
time and strange storytelling sure
uh the the story I think we're gonna
talk we're gonna be talking about this I
think a lot but it came it came at me
in a very weird way
um I used to think that we created our
own stories I used to think that it was
a matter of uh kind of sitting down and
assembling certain pieces of
things together you know reading Russian
fairy tales coming up with a concept
from that kind of weirdly meshing things
and then allowing the story to come out
of the structure
um not necessarily I'm an outliner or
anything like this but it your story is
usually used to come out from from a
fairly regimented and structured uh kind
of approach to to writing for me
but um right around covet time this
probably would have been it's already
more than two years ago now I was I took
a course with our mutual friend Paul
kingsnorth uh which which was called
rewilding your words
I didn't know what it what what was
going to happen but I knew that it was
something that I needed to experience
just because Paul was such a compelling
figure and I was really curious to see
what would happen and I came in with the
with one idea of what I would do I
thought okay this is going to help me
write more beautiful setting like it's
gonna allow me to uh to make my writing
more pretty basically and what it did
instead was break me in in pieces
um the course is wonderful uh uh
Jonathan you and I are are members of uh
are both teachers in a new program that
we talked about uh on on a different
podcast Saint Basil School of writing
Paul's joined us there but
um he's teaching a version of that of
this uh
course for St basil school and so I'm
really excited to see how that's going
to work because
it's he what he effectively does is that
it doesn't teach you anything about how
to structure or craft your writing he
teaches you how to how to be in tune
with the natural world around you in
ways that will then allow
for a story to emerge that's almost a
kind of duet between you and and the
world that you live in
so he speaks a lot about allowing the
setting the place to be a character in
and of itself he writes that way you've
read the wake I think although you read
beast beast yeah yeah well the the
setting there is I mean the Beast is the
setting in a lot of ways and although
the creature does show up at the in the
end it's a kind of incarnation you know
of of the of the land that he is having
this spiritual battle it's so key he has
this very strong sense in his own
writing of that
um and what it did for me is it it
opened up an entirely new and different
way of accessing the what Tolkien would
call The Cauldron of story that kind of
uh common source that everybody takes
their stories from but in a way that
isn't structured in a way that isn't
planned in a way that is very surprising
and very odd and it fit for me at that
moment because as the world was
crumbling around me
um a lot of people went the opposite way
right they went to the Super regimented
kind of Lifestyles and sometimes that
came out in in the tenor of the way that
they talked about it right you have to
find structure in your side yourself you
you try to write regiment everything
around you try to find the reason why
these things are happening you become
rational you become hyper
um rationalistic in either one direction
or the other right we've seen we've seen
both extremes during the pandemic
um that is not good for story
uh it's it doesn't I mean you could
write stories out of that and in fact
many of the stories that we're watching
right now on Disney plus and all the
other streams uh are coming from exactly
that thing
um I don't want to do that I had no
desire to do that yeah those stories end
up looking like utilitarian or
propaganda they they tend to be focused
on a kind of really clear purpose let's
say in terms of the story yeah
definitely well it's I mean Purpose
Driven or theme driven storytelling is
something that everybody does right so
it's not it's not it's necessarily a bad
thing but when your purpose
um
overwhelms the story
uh I noticed it for the first time
actually when I saw one division
um there was there were a few scenes in
there when the writers stopped writing a
story and they started to write a
lecture yeah and it was really it was
really annoying it took me out of the
story completely and it shouldn't have
because that was such a experimental and
weird
um kind of uh story that one the one
division was where at least it was
trying to be I don't think It ultimately
succeeded I don't think it was very good
but
um one of the things that went against
it was that they didn't lean into the
weirdness the weirdness became window
dressing for for a very conventional
story
um that you know if I haven't watched uh
doctor strange but I I've read about it
and I know that that you were exactly
right in your predictions about this
being simply nothing more than than
self-crowning like a kind of yeah it's
really bad apogee yeah but it's
interesting to notice how the let's say
because I grew up in a in a product kind
of Evangelical world and I wrote three
plays that were within that context and
had some Evangelistic purposes like
that's not all they were but they
definitely needed to have that inside
the play right and every time I remember
like I remember writing them and real
and and writing it and realizing oh I
need to have that moment yeah like
moment in the play and I cringe every
time I every time I think of it and now
when I watch that's why I find it so
difficult to watch
Christian movies I had such a deep a
deep uh experience with that because I
wrote three of those myself and I
produced them and we toured and we did
all that and so it's like when I see it
I'm like oh this is so painful but I
never thought that I would see it in the
Hollywood movies as much as I'm seeing
it now so it's interesting because it's
because it's bad screenwriting
everything everybody knows this bad
screener but uh there's something going
on in Hollywood not I don't know if we
want to talk about this too much but
it's becoming clear more and more and so
this is something that came out in Barry
Weiss's podcast or may have been her sub
stack but she talked about how and I'm
not I'm not quoting this so if I'm
getting it wrong I do apologize but she
basically was quoting an Insider who
said that after the George Floyd
um riots there was a a
mandate from Heaven yeah
a mandate from not heaven uh that said
get rid of all the old guys and uh make
sure you diversify your core now the the
issue is the problem is and the this
Insider was very open about it I think
uh I don't know if it's a he or she I
believe he was anonymous
uh made it clear that the pool of
possible screenwriters is small as it is
because the life of a screenwright in
Hollywood is absolutely miserable you
get you get paid almost nothing and
you're working in you're working for
these big shots that basically force you
to do stuff and then put their own
writing on top of yours they put their
name on your writing right and that's
that's something that you accept if you
want to live that life but there's not a
lot of people that do and of those that
are already there there's not that great
of a percentage of of a diverse
population so in sort of shoehorning in
the Mandate what's happening is not that
these people can't tell good stories
it's that they haven't had the training
and they're put in positions of you know
leader of writing room uh and they're
trying to tell good stories but they
haven't been trained in in the absolute
basics of Storytelling so they're
defaulting to what they're seeing in the
New York Times and in the cultural uh
conversation which is a top-down
speaking interwagging Yeah but that I
mean that kills that kills the immersion
and story within as soon as it happens
and it doesn't matter what side you're
on yeah even if you agree with it you're
not in the story anymore you've just
been pulled out
definitely so it brings us to our major
point which is in this strange
topsy-turvy times when even those let's
say that
those that would portray even themselves
as being the margin are now becoming
more or less than finger wagging like
what kind of story can we tell and how
can we tell this story well that was
that was my thought you know and of
course as soon as I had I thought I had
to abandon the thought because if I
start thinking like that then the story
I'm going to tell is not going to be
story forward but it's going to be theme
forward so if I'm thinking I need to
tell a story that's going to embrace the
margins that's it I've lost the game
right so this is this is weird dance and
you know this your your creative you
understand especially a creative within
within a you know within the tradition
bound
um craft such as iconography there's
always a dance between
um what you want to do and what the
tradition tells you to do
and and what you hope uh you're able to
do in terms of your personal uh input
but also you you want
you want to add something new just you
that's also a dance with with the with
the tradition it's it's weird it's it
it's a very strange it's very diff for
that moment when uh I think in
particular when the premise becomes
available to you especially after after
Paul's Court yeah so of course was to
was to be able to write the kind of
premise that would be able to embrace
the the margin that would be able to
nudge people in that want them to think
and feel but without preaching to them
and I tried to write it but from from a
place where I was
where I had a very clear idea of what I
wanted to happen right and it was a
disaster it really didn't work I wrote a
few scenes of this thing uh I had an
idea of who the main character was I had
an idea of who's what his motivations
were going to be
and I wrote it it was flowing
beautifully and I put it aside for a bit
stuff happened life Etc and I got back
to it and I started to read it and I
hated I hated it with a with a burning
passion it was like this is the worst
thing I have ever written and I've been
writing for years now this is this has
not happened
um so I tried to remember all Kings
North's um lessons I tried to let go of
the story I I tried to let go of what I
wanted the story to be I still had a
sense of
the of who the character was I had a
sense of what the setting was the timing
within the larger um
within the larger uh world that I ride
in
and it took me going out into nature
literally and being
in the in the fresh air and not thinking
not listening to podcasts not talking to
anybody but just being in the world not
the mechanical world of the city but out
there because I live you know in cow
country
so it took it took me being out there
for suddenly this thing to hit me and go
boom this is where you have to go and it
wasn't me you know I don't know what it
was and I'm not the kind of person to
say God spoke to me and therefore and
then I sat down and I wrote this thing
and it was it was a cooperation between
me and God now I'm not going to say that
but whatever that voice was it was there
and it was outside of myself and it then
then began the song and from then on out
it it just wrote it just wrote itself
and it's different from the from the
other stuff I wrote in a lot of ways
it's a different voice it's a different
kind of um
uh it's it's a different kind of
character it's a different kind of
approach to storytelling and I think I
hope uh it's basically I embraced my my
fairy tale telling instincts so instead
of trying to tell an Epic Fantasy
according to the Epic Fantastical uh
rule book and there is a rule book of
Epic Fantasy there there are steps that
you have to follow there are things you
have to do otherwise the reasons are
like this is an Epic Fantasy I'll never
read this again so I threw that out and
I said no I'm telling a fairy tale and
I'm not retelling a fairy tale I'm
telling a new one
which is what people used to do all the
time
and it used to be the center thing right
it was the center of town it was where
the fireplace was is wherever everybody
gathered in the evenings of the village
this used to be the activity of the
center
and now the center is downtown now the
center is Facebook now the center is
whatever political Insanity we're living
through at the moment the center is the
thing that has gone utterly Bonkers so
in going back to an older form of
Storytelling I hope
oddly enough I'm now I think I hope
embracing the storytelling tropes and
techniques of the margin
which means what for you what do you
think that means
um well it it started it starts off with
the process of writing itself in
allowing the story to
not be entirely limited by
the the tropes of what people expect it
to be
so it's a difficult thing to
to balance the entertainment factor of a
story because everybody wants to have a
certain repeated pattern of course
with the uh with the freshness the
newness of a story that has never been
told before but that has to have they
have to be both you can't have a story
that's so unique and so new that has
that you know that's never been told
that nobody can relate to
um that's you know Marcel Deshawn that's
that's uh that's and yeah yeah Eternal
music that's all that's all the stuff
that we've been we had to go through for
the past 50 100 years right so you have
to figure out
how to how to do that but it also means
um
I think it means telling stories that
are weird telling stories that are
bizarre using imagery that doesn't
necessarily
have immediate associations in people's
minds
choosing characters that are fools
choosing characters that are children
and
allowing the the the setting of the
world itself that you're writing to
become a character
and to dictate what happens
so this is really weird and it's very
hard to do because a setting isn't a
character has no motivations it's a
thing
but there are stories out there and
they're very interesting things like
Alice in Wonderland like the Gorman Goss
Trilogy by by Mervin Peak like Lord of
the Rings
um where the setting itself is actually
a character it it determines what what
the human characters
do within the story to a large extent
it's not simply because there's
mountains here and there's then there's
you know a river there that you have to
cross it's that the place itself has has
its own spirit and that spirit will
determine how the how the characters
react as they walk through it
that's not something you see in a lot of
modern storytelling um because it's
dangerous
because you don't know what's going to
happen and you have to be as a
Storyteller you have to be more
connected to Natural the natural world
to be able to do that realistically
because if you're a writer who sits in a
Garrett all day and has never walked
outside and has never had the experience
of touching a tree and feeling what the
bark of a tree actually feels like has
never seen the changing seasons on the
same road year and year out and how the
how the trees change in their color how
they change in their shape and how just
being in the same spot walking the same
path every day for 365 days
means that every single day is different
this kind of rootedness this kind of
being in place
I produces very strong storytelling in
good storytellers I'm not including
myself in the list yet eventually
hopefully but it's what I'm aiming for
and it's what I was trying to begin and
it's what Paul kingsner does so well
it's what Tolkien did so well he was a
rooted man he was a man who was stuck in
place right he didn't travel a lot he
but he was very at what at one with his
with his natural world
not this you know jet-setting crazy
world that we live in where you go on a
plane every time you need to go to on
vacation where you're sorry Jonathan I
know that you're you're about to enter
into that world yourself traveling
so you sent me you sent me a quote by
Martin Shaw who for those who don't know
Martin Shaw he's a mythologist
Storyteller from Ireland he's been kind
of appearing in this little corner I
guess of the internet because he's had
some he's a friend of Paul Kings North
and he's had some some uh intimations of
Christianity and Orthodoxy something
which he thought he'd never uh would
have I'm going to talk to him in the
next few months I'm not sure what what
day exactly but it's gonna happen so you
send me this quote by him and you said
when the center is in crisis it is to
the edges that we must attend and so I
thought that sounded a lot like when I
say something like watch the pools you
know that the the carnival in the end
will flip back into will bring back a
kind of normal world but what is it that
you think
that this can do for us at this moment
well it I think we're we are
storytelling creatures we know that we
talk about it a lot and you and I have
talked about this repeatedly and I think
we've become even a little bit too
complacent in the idea that stories will
change the world we simply have to tell
a good story I don't think that's true
uh as as much as I thought before and
that's because
we have a very educated and a very
cultured
um
people
now there's there are a lot of a lot of
people that have access to high
education
and they're used to
the kind of good storytelling that we're
not seeing right now on television and
that's why you're seeing so much
discontent in so many quarters about
about the the level of quality
but there's a yes people are
discontented with the bad storytelling
but it doesn't necessarily mean that if
you give them good stories they're going
to live good lives the proof in the
pudding is that if you listen to all
these people people like the critical
Drinker and and his ilk that have been
uh critiquing the the new Lord of the
Rings series even before they managed to
see it uh there
a reference point where their
relationship with with the show is
almost one of religious awe
um they they
for them the experience of the story has
has become a Akin to
uh a religious experience and so when
it's wrong they react to it not as
frustrated artists
but as people who walked into a
heretical church right don't don't
recognize the exclamations or recognize
the exclamations as being
um
exactly no that's a really good analogy
it seems for sure that people that are
freaking out about this new Lord of the
Rings series are really acting as if
there is a heresy in front of them and
it has to be denounced it has to be
expunged you know it has to be and and
you don't have to watch the thing it's
it's enough to know a few facts it's
enough to listen to the uh to the
character the actors talk about the
thing it's enough to listen to the the
the show Runners talk about the thing to
be able to have all the necessary
information that you need to battle the
heresy because they're they're apologies
they're not storytellers well some of
them are but
um and I'm saying this not to not to
make fun of them
um I I understand what's going on I
think and it's uh it's it's a function
of where we are in this civilization
it's a function of the decadence of of
Western Christendom in the level that it
is at the Historical moment that it is
so that means that if we simply I think
if we simply revert to a kind of
uh hero's journey archetypal story over
and over and over again like we've
talked about like Star Wars then the
best that we can hope for is the kind of
uh cultural dominance through
merchandising and LARPing that Star Wars
has managed to exert over the world yeah
and if you you know if obviously most
people know that this is the case if you
don't read the book how Star Wars
conquered the universe it's a
fascinating history of the of the lore
and and what happened it just gives you
an idea of just how much this has a
religious character for people who you
know the kinds of people that build from
scratch Stormtrooper suits or the Darth
Vader suit not thinking for a moment of
course the Darth Vader is supposed to be
the figure of evil because it's not
about that
um so it's I don't think it's enough to
have this kind of
a watered down heroes or anything
anymore
although we do need to have the kinds of
fairy tale structures that Tolkien talks
about in in his essay on fairy stories
they the the structures that lead to the
EU catastrophe the the sudden flip at
the end
the way that we get there has to be
weird now it has to be odd it has to be
unexpected it has to be bizarre
purposely right and in Russia you see
this by the way in modern literature so
Russia for because of the Soviet Union
and because of um the predominance of
social realism things like this the way
that the writers responded to it was by
writing absurdist
um uh
what's the technical term like super
absurdist
um
magical realism yeah like Master and
Margarita like Master Margarita exactly
that's the first one but then it went
even crazier with people like Victor
pilavia who's a very well-known and very
well-known author internationally and is
a consistent bestseller in Russia and
writes absolutely insane nihilistic
crazy flipped bizarreness and people
drink eat it up in Russia they love it
because
because they understand that he is a
fool and he is very wise so
our job now is very difficult because we
could go that route
we could go the root of the of the
absolute negator
uh we Master Margarita did that very
well but in order to do that
uh he had to rewrite the history of the
Gospel in a way that negated Christ's
Divinity that was the only way he was
going to be able to tell that story in a
way that would work so you have this
incredible novel that that has a very
problematic uh moral heart to it
uh it's all about nihilism in a lot of
ways yeah as a response to this kind of
good versus evil inverted thing that the
Soviet Union was was pushing down in
everybody else's throats so we can't go
there it's dangerous right because
because if we're honest about what we
have to do as storytellers we have these
we have our listeners souls in our in
our hands right cupped in our hands they
if you're a good writer as soon as
you've plunged the uh the reader into
your world you're responsible for what
happens to that person in that world
it's it's scary yeah but it's it's true
so you have to unsettle them
you have to go to Dark Places you have
to mess up their their very comfortable
presuppositions about what the world is
but you also have to do it in a way that
reinforces the pattern the pattern of
reality as you talk about all the time
that's an incredibly hard thing to do
technically a storytellers and that's
the challenge that's ahead of us and
that's what Martin Shaw is doing
uh in in talking about his that quote
specifically he writes really bizarre
weird stuff that's very French and very
like kind of prose poetry kind of stuff
that's that's very
on the verge of paganism Christianity
inspired by
um you know the ancient myths but also
speaking them in a language that's
understandable and if you allow yourself
to enter into it it can be really very
interesting and very transformative in a
lot of ways
hmm
and so who do you see as being do you
see Loris as being an example of that
yes for example right yeah Loris is
funny because uh on the one hand it's
it's very it's a very conventional
narrative it's it's it follows all the
Beats of the saints saint life of a
particular kind of Saint life but if
you're paying attention
um does it and if you're reading it
carefully especially if you're reading
it in Russian the translation is good
but it doesn't it doesn't do absolute
justice as Noah's translation of course
can I can say that I'm a translator uh
um there are some profoundly shocking
moments in Loris there's some really
awful things that happen in Loris
um the the death of of his of his wife
and child uh you know the inciting
incident that leads to his becoming a
snake they're described in details that
nobody should ever describe when talking
about women and children yeah um really
horrifying stuff
so that's one thing then there's also
like he pushes the limits of what of
what we consider to be saintly yeah when
you have the pugnacious uh fools for
Christ you know duking it out while
walking on water walking on water yeah
man that stuff is crazy
I mean
a lot of people are like this you can't
have this this isn't this isn't right
but if you've heard also The Verge on
masochism which he brings his character
to here sometimes you're wondering like
is this just a kind of strange uh
masochism like a kind of nihilistic
masochism or is this an actual negation
of self like when he lets himself get
stung by all the mosquitoes and stuff
and you're like what you know really yes
and well actually that I think you may
have taken that from from an actual life
of one of the Russian Saints yeah um so
that that has that has happened but even
like that's the thing about the lives of
the Saints too is that when you read
them there's is some of that in there
right we we tend to iron out the lives
of the Saints or the medieval Legends
we've kind of made them nice and clean
even the fairy tales we made them nice
and clean a lot of the versions of the
fairy tales that we have now
have have taken out all the strangeness
that was there just a few a few
centuries ago and that's been one of my
ideas is to how can we bring back the
strangeness or some of the things that
are that seem off color to to
contemporary morality or sensibilities
but use it in a way that is revelatory
rather than just a kind of shocking for
Scandal or shocking right shocking like
I've been thinking about like the
Rapunzel for example but in the original
Rapunzel stories Rapunzel gets pregnant
in the tower we've expunged that
completely from all the versions that we
tell our kids but I kept thinking
without that it actually is weakening
what the story is about and the idea of
the man who forgets the mother of his
children you know in this in his fall
and then has to hear her voice again in
order to recognize her I'm like no we
need to put that back in like is is
there a way to put it back in even in a
story for kids uh especially in a moment
where kids are no longer like naive
innocent and and innocent the way that
we wish they were because they're well
you say no longer but I'm not sure if
they ever were they ever were exactly
yeah so is there a way to put that back
to put it back in which would reveal a
higher aspect of the story rather than
just be for shot but that's just that's
edgy like for kids it's not that hard
because you won't go as far but for
adults it's a
how can I say this like it's a it can be
really tricky because they're well so
much so much of the modern fiction is
like is shock a lot of it has a lot of
shock for shock value for sure
so um those of you who are watching on
YouTube will see that we've suddenly uh
and magically changed our appearance
um
and there's a reason for that uh we had
technical difficulties because we were
about to say something so incredible
interesting astounding yeah that nobody
out there wanted it to happen
um in actual fact I was running out of
ideas and it was a really good thing
that happened because then I had to go
back and and uh
yeah and read up on a little bit of jock
Dairy da and stuff like that and
a little evening of post-structuralist
theory you know you know just a little
bit of difference in my life you know
there you go exactly what I need no but
in all seriousness
um it was probably a good thing because
uh I was uh as we talked as we talked
about before
um I do like to allow my thoughts to
kind of wander when I'm out there uh
running around in in the wild which I do
fairly a lot of because I train for a
certain kind of sport called adventure
racing which we will not talk about
today but anyway
um I was uh thinking about
uh yesterday
uh the idea of how modernity fractures
Us and how
um what what what the value of shock is
to to let
fractured people realize they're
fractured and this is where we this is
where we ended last time we were talking
about how with this kinds of stories
that we're that that were being
subjected to the kind of stories that
we're surrounded by
um it's very it's it's difficult to
avoid
as a as a writer as a maker as a Creator
uh to use it's difficult to avoid using
shock just to get people out of a very
comfortable buffered state that they
exist in because the reality is that
everybody is really seriously fractured
as a result of modernity and until we
realize that we are that fractured there
really can't be any sort of integration
or wholeness that can happen within the
single person much less the larger
society
which was of course made so obvious by
the pandemic and it's I think it's a
mistake to think that the pandemic
caused it uh the pandemic just made it
obvious yeah just eccentricated it
revealed something that was there yeah
it accentuated but it also revealed how
deep that fracturing went and I think
it's important also to to emphasize that
that fracturing really is within each
individual person it's not just a matter
of some people being revealed to have
very dangerous ideologies that now must
all be explained right it's not that
everybody was an aunt it was a fascist
and now the fascists have to be removed
no it's all of us are are broken all of
us are fractured and that's a function
of the culture of modernity
um and I was listening to this podcast
uh yesterday and this will connect back
to how the margins work with
storytelling in a second but
um the this was a really interesting
conversation between two makers and one
of them suggested that
uh
there's that the the connection between
uh fragmentation or fracturing that's
happening around us and the need for I
for the search for identity is not
accidental
because identity he was saying in its
root the word identity is connected to
uh Oneness is connected to Unity so
I was it's been this is a thought that's
been percolating in my head and I
haven't been able to fully articulate it
yet maybe you can help me do that maybe
we can do that for the rest of what's
happening today but
it's really striking to me that
as lit as literacy declines
as people's engagement with old stories
declines as people become inundated more
and more in the kind of commercialized
visual culture that we have
identity seems to slip away more and
more from people and they and they grasp
for it a lot stronger so if you're
considering for example this really
bizarre and strange and terrifying thing
that's happening especially with young
girls where there were so many of them
are now
reaching out and searching for an
identity that is other because they feel
uncomfortable with the fracturing within
them
What If part of the problem is that
there has never has not been enough
of a
integration through a story that has
been available to people in traditional
cultures because the traditional culture
has always embraced the journey to the
toward the other through a search of
identity by crossing the line between
the center and the margin by going from
the village into the forest but if there
is no common tradition of Storytelling
and if the stories that we do tell that
are a proxy for that common traditional
storytelling are the new Marvel or the
new Star Wars then where are you are all
of us going to find that internal
integration
if it's not being offered in Story the
only other option
for some people is surgery I mean this
is a thought that that I'm grasping for
and I haven't been able fully to
articulate it yet but I think there
might be something to it I think there
might be something
to the fact that maybe we just need
a better unifying story that is shocking
because we need to have that moment of
shock initially
to for for the person to realize that
their internal world is incredibly
fractured and if I can extend that a
little bit what really disturbs me is
that amongst people who do not like the
idea of a unifying story or a common
storytelling tradition people generally
tend to be more on more in the liberal
uh scale of things it is almost anathema
to suggest that there is such a thing as
taste that there is such a thing as good
storytelling versus bad storytelling all
they can do is say I have my preferences
you have yours and don't you dare
suggest to me that my preference is in
some way inferior to yours
it's just a matter of taste but not
taste in the in the larger
um organic uh objective sense of taste
being determined by taste makers being
determined by by cultural norms right
it's a kind of personal thing that is in
effect especially in the in extreme
cases a kind of following of your
passions so why this is why you have
people who read 300 books a year that
all of them have the same theme they all
they're all basically the same plot
structure they're the same character the
same type of characters the same tropes
they just keep reinforcing and most of
them are trash it keeps reinforcing the
same
fuzzy warm buffered feeling that
separates you from the knowledge of your
own internal fragmentation
um so I don't know I don't know uh well
I think that oh so I think that your
intuition about identity is definitely
right that's for sure that's for sure
and the way to understand it
um the best way to understand what's
going on is to understand how
let's say how sin Works in us or how our
passions work with us and so one of the
things that happened so let's say we
could you could say as Christians we
could say something like our identity
is full to the extent that we
participate in the body of Christ to the
extent that we are little Christ that
Christ in us like all the ways that
Saint Paul talks about like that is the
fullness of our identity and so in a way
it is it's the fullness of you but it's
also transpersonal that is it pulls you
out of your idiosyncratic you know uh
self uh and so then you have within you
you you have these pulls and these
thoughts and these these passions that
they they capture you and when they
capture you they actually try to make
you think that that's all you are
yeah you know especially in the moment
when you're when you're let's say taken
by the passion it's like the passion
takes over and that's what you are and
so if you understand that at a and the
those passions and those idiosyncratic
patterns they have a they have an
appearance and they have a mythological
appearance right they actually have a an
appearance in storytelling
um it appearance in in in art you know
and it's the demons it's like it's the
mixture it's the Dark Shadows in the
Eastern tradition these dark kind of
Shadows or in the western tradition it's
these hybrid Monsters uh that come to
torture you right this all this this is
this is a
it's not like it like it's not
completely objective like a scientific
fact but it has a universality to it
which which is which is pervasive and so
what we're seeing is that's what we're
seeing like we're seeing those little
identities take over people and that's
why they look the way they look that
there is no yeah if there's no hiding
anymore it's like the right right and
that's what that's why the hybridization
is happening especially in Western
people like the Western people are are
clamoring for that hybridization because
they think in that mixing of things is
going to be some sort of full expression
of the self of the of the internal
Integrity of the self which is so if you
look at it from the side and and don't
and try to just be dispassionate about
it it's total Madness that's total
Madness but okay so this this then
extends so this is I have another
thought about that because that's what
you're talking about then is a kind of
full
um immersion in a dangerous other
while without realizing it that you're
doing it because you think you're
searching for the self but actually what
you're doing is letting in another
another and that other will then subsume
you it'll it'll possess you right and
this can happen in stories too now so
this is what's so interesting about the
old uh storytelling tropes right the old
storytelling uh Styles is that they
allow you to fully inhabit in a safe
space the idea of being the other
because that's what reading is right if
if you're reading and you're reading you
are in the mind and behind the eyes of a
character that isn't you that is a
different sex there's a different skin
color that's a different social uh
status you are fully inhabiting as much
as that's possible uh that person's
experience and you're allowing that
person's experience to to inform your
own so you're simultaneously learning
more about yourself you're becoming more
integrated in yourself but you're also
doing that by setting interesting and
useful boundaries between you and the
other while also having an experience of
the other that allows for a very um into
integrating type things so you it's you
are a self but you're also other without
losing self right well that's because
yeah well that's because the space of
imagination has a certain quality to it
it's not this it's in the imaginary
space is the Fantastical space is not
the same as the space with which you
identify just so so I think that that's
that's hard for people it might seem
like an obvious thing to say but it is
it is real so like let's say
storytelling it's not the only function
it can have but like you said it can
have an exploratory function but that
exploratory function is one which is
which is recognizing that I'm entering
into a Fantastical space which is not my
space which is not me whereas what one
of the things that's going on in terms
of the um so that's one aspect of
Storytelling it's not the only one there
is an aspect of Storytelling which is
also my story like you you know the
Trojan War is not a Fantastical
storytelling right it's my story it's
the story that I remember that I engaged
liturgically and participated and that's
the same with the gospel stories or the
same with you know the the liturgical
year as the story that we participate in
and engage with but the more Fantastical
type Stories the ones that are like like
you said where you you take you take the
role of another let's say they have a
function but I think that what's going
on and that's one of the reasons why
Star Wars is becoming a religion is that
we've made it upside down we've made
this weird upside down relationship
where we want to be some anime like you
know anime character we want to be Luke
Skywalker or we want to live in these
imaginary worlds
uh and we hate our own story like we
hate our own history we hate our own our
our own Legends uh and so you can see I
mean it really is a an image of the of
the end like it is an image of this
upside down place where now everything
is and then then that upside down place
has many iterations many forms it can
look like that strangeness of of Cosplay
but it can also look like you said which
is the fetishization of strangeness and
a desire to take all strangeness into
myself becoming become a hybrid animal
you know fetishize uh uh you know and
now we're seeing more like the race
changing where people are wanting to be
another race or you know it's like all
of these types of behaviors can
demonstrate the problem
the problem the confusion or even the
inversion between the idea of a of a
story which is remembering my my con my
connection and the story which is this
exploratory dream like experience of you
know of uh yeah of fighting monsters and
doing so it's it's an inversion of
hierarchy again oh yeah for sure there's
no doubt about that it is that it's like
a weird upside down place that we're
standing in
there are ways to flip it I think and I
think that that's the space that we're
in and that it's an exciting space
actually to be in which is you know can
we tell
the Fantastical stories in a way
that will surprise us back into our own
story or can we tell the our our story
in a way that will be slightly
Fantastical but to shock us back into it
you know I think that that's definitely
possible right now
well it's it seems to be the the best
time for it I mean I've talked before
about how fantasy as a storytelling
um is a storytelling mechanism is just
better right now because people have
become saturated with the storytelling
um approaches of realistic fiction and
because in 20th century in the in the
20th century realistic fiction has
become little more than a my story that
is nothing that is almost nothing more
than a constant regurgitation of
internal
fragmentation and yeah who would want to
read that so yeah very small group
people who are who very much you know
appreciate that internal regurgitation
because that's all they do all day yeah
but you know for the rest of us
um let's find something a little bit
different
yeah and so I think that like if you
follow the the line let's say between
someone if you follow the line also
between like realistic fiction if you
look at the 19th century romantic and
the early 20th century realists and then
you move into the surprise of of of
Lewis and token and the inklings and
this kind of weird the surprise it was
already there like it is a continuation
of the romantics to a certain extent
yeah but it's an interesting idea like I
really like the idea that token and C.S
Lewis were kind of writing the Old
Testament
for us like an Old Testament for for for
today which is that how can we now make
that next step and I there are probably
several Solutions but the one that I
decided that we decided my brother and I
was to tell a Fantastical version of our
story in a way that is is in some way
scandalous because it's like it's
changing the character that's doing all
this but it's hopefully pointing you
back towards your own real legendarium
like to our own true legendarium
which you know in order to be able to
engage with that legendarium you have to
come to love it again and
um that's that's the that's the trick
and the trouble here and unfortunately
uh it is it is a critical moment for
that because as I'm as I'm looking at
attempted expressions of this such as
the new rings of power show which I've
only started to watch
um there this internal conflict is
between Cree uh loving your old
legendarium and telling it in a fresh
way
or rewriting the old legendarium to fit
the bed better than you paradigm that
conflict is very strong in that show
yeah and it's it's very interesting to
see it pan out and part part of it is
just stupid storytelling choices but
part of it is this is this insistence
and
I okay so I I'm probably getting trouble
for for raising this in the first place
but the idea of uh diverse casting is
you can argue about this and you can
talk about this actually much longer
than people are willing to to do because
most people either come come into one of
two extreme camps one uh you're a racist
uh two uh you're a woke garbage person
right uh and neither the twain shall
meet ever but uh there have been very
interesting examples of of diverse
casting in in films that I like very
much in the 90s there was a wonderful
Shakespeare adaptation called much to do
about nothing by Kenneth Brana that used
colorblind casting
um and as a kid initially my first
impress my first impression of a black
guy and Keanu Reeves being Blood
Brothers was like huh but like within
the first five minutes of it passing I'm
like okay this is I don't care because
the actors are so good but of course
this is Shakespeare and it's been
adapted so many different times in so
many different ways that there's a lot
of space for it to be adapted in new and
interesting ways so that's one possible
way of looking at it the problem is
though of course that the way the reason
that most of the pro people for diverse
casting are talking about this is the
following
you have this vast swath of young people
who have a certain skin color and they
read Tolkien and they see token on the
screen and they cannot associate
themselves with the characters on the
screen or on the page
therefore we must change the skin color
of some of the main characters so that
these poor children are able to
associate with those uh imagined
characters and inhabit this Fantastical
space which is a proposition that is
extremely flawed because it's ridiculous
because it's a fantastic world like it's
not right I mean it's not real like
and yeah oh man my point is that it
removes from the table the possibility
that one can have an experience of
another that is integrative and that is
and that doesn't remove the experience
of the self so that's that's something
that I find problematic I'll leave it
there because it is a very authority
issue but my point is that you're right
this is a very interesting moment
because this show could have been
something that started to reintegrate
people on a large scale I think that the
Peter Jackson movies started to do it
even though they took they took a few um
wrong turns in some of the
interpretation but we'll look at General
look at let me give you an example of
someone who actually did that right now
and and it's funny because it's not our
lead it's it's the it's the guy that
he's haunting me is so so Neil Neil
Gaiman wrote a version of the the
northern Gods Legend yeah and and it's
perfect
like it's it's super well told it's very
respectful of the story it's basically a
retelling of these Legends in a way that
is celebratory that that has a kind of
bombastic uh
um feel to it you know it has this this
energy to it and the of course the only
reason why he could do that is because
it's not Christian like it's a it's it's
Northern and it's vegan and therefore
it's okay to do that but yeah I mean the
the technique and the style and the
possibility is there for us to to take
like we could do that for some of the a
lot let's say a lot think of all the the
wild stories from the golden legend or
from Russian uh yeah Russian fairy tales
yeah or the Russian fairy tales nobody
knows these stories uh and they could be
retold in ways that would surprise
everybody the Middle Ages is actually an
amazing Source because because it's the
Dark Ages Nobody Knows the stories like
nobody knows the legends of Alexander
nobody knows some of a lot of these
Arthurian romances uh you like I made a
video on this Arthurian romance called
silence you know which is so fascinating
I mean like Merlin is in it is this like
crazy man who laughs the whole time oh
my God crazy Merlin is the greatest
character ever I love crazy it's like
it's like he shows up in the really
ancient Welsh uh Legends the guy was
nuts he was off his rocker crazy it's
like so interesting yeah like a wild end
of the forest and so it's like that
version of Merlin could be retold could
be told in a way that could be super
fascinating for people to discover and
but there's that's just one example
there are many many other examples and
so it seemed like it's a I I really do
feel like it's a it could be an exciting
moment and also because when they reach
when let's say when the the people in
Hollywood you know redo the Green Knight
yeah they fail like I don't know what to
tell you they fail because they're
they're they're crippled with their
their desire to to inject their message
into it and so because of it they they
don't do a good job
well yeah because well it's not just
their desire to inject a message it's
these people like the director of the
green I have a lot of respect from he's
a very interesting person and I think
he's trying to do something
um well so the problem is that these
people honestly believe
um that meaning can only be made by the
self without a reference point to an
objective standard and this this calls
this harks back to that graphic artists
um that you talk to the the famous guy
from Ben hatke his his um his absolute
resistance to considering the
possibility of there being a best story
ever told because then it it means that
my story the one I have to make for
myself the meaning making mechanism that
I have will be somehow will be somehow
impoverished because there's something
greater than me instead of seeing it as
a possibility to align yourself as much
as humanly possible to
to an infinitely beautiful model
it becomes a limiting factor because
meaning must be made only within but you
know what it's happening already it's
happening it's happening on the edges on
the margins they're you know the
aforementioned Martin Shaw uh did a
collaboration with uh with a now
recently deceased poet named Tony
Hoagland called cinderbiter which by the
way if you have if you people haven't
read it you have to it's a retelling of
ancient Celtic uh folk tales in modern
poetic form obviously this is marginal
stuff not a lot of people are going to
read it but it's life-changing poetry it
really is and if you can force yourself
to get through it it's really incredible
uh Paul King's North stories are also
marginal but they're that's what they're
doing they're engaging with uh deep very
profound real
um objective realities that form
they can't have the possibility of
forming our internal reality
um who else I had somebody else well I
mean when I read that when I read Beast
I was I was astounded it was like
because I I you know when I was younger
I was also I was one of those people
that read a lot of modern literature and
and when I read Beast I was like this is
like tokien and decade like how did
token come together and it's like Smash
and I thought this is a real interesting
possibility like to take James Joy like
for example there's things in James
Joyce which are astoundingly powerful
and there's some things in James Joyce
with her which are just like unbearably
horrible I guess you know and so so you
there are some Indulgence like the
desire in modernism to unite form form
and meaning even in the grammar and in
the manner in like the structure like
that's something which can be taken and
can be can be used for very very
powerful means because that's what you
have well that's what T.S Eliot did so
well that's what TS Eliot did so well in
all of his poetry right so if you but
again you need that shock right you need
to be shocked into it because if you
just come into it without uh without
being prepared it wash over you it's too
difficult it's too it's too structurally
vast it's complicated
um so okay well I just remembered
another one that's doing it so Richard
Powers is a is a Pulitzer prize-winning
um author he wrote a book called The
overstory now he used to be a guy who
lived in Tech
um and I listened to an interview with
him between him and Ezra Klein who's
somebody that's very much on the left
and somebody that I listen to as a
palette cleanser for me to to remember
why I think the way I do just to
remember how the other side
oh Lord okay anyway
um so
Richard Powers is a guy who used to sit
at table with the the uh Silicon Valley
Tech people who used to honestly in all
earnestness talk about just hold on a
little more and immortality is within
our grasp whether it's biological or
it's informational I mean these are
actual serious conversations that these
people are having so like cryogenically
freezing my brain Etc that sort of thing
right the sort of thing that C.S Lewis
described so beautifully in That Hideous
Strength
um you know and that by the way a lot of
people are uh recognizing that this
Kevin Kelly kind of technology has its
own will thing is actually just an entry
point for demonic Powers but um but
Richard Powers was in this and he's he
finally kind of snapped out of it and
the reason he snapped out of it is
because he recognized that my personal
meaning making mechanism as he expressed
it my way of making meaning and he's
somebody who's capable of doing it a
writer somebody who's who's extremely
well read uh educated living in a very
culturally Rich place the the Bay Area
of San Francisco and California
surrounded by the best the brightest
people in the world and his meaning
making meaning making mechanism broke
down
he was unable to make it anymore and
where did he find it in as he calls it
the more than human world he he went out
into nature and he found in their
presences that were greater than he in
his mind of course that's you know what
he's actually feeling
um I dare say is an inkling of natural
Revelation it's the same thing that Paul
King's North felt uh when he was a
Wiccan priest the same thing that Martin
Shaw is now feeling when when you know
as he says Jesus rescued me to the
ground and when it wouldn't let me get
up Jesus the the mossy faced Jesus that
he that he encountered in the wild uh so
what happens on the edges what happens
on the margins is indicative of what's
going to be mainstream in 10 15 20 years
yeah if that's the case then let's get
going and let's start writing into that
space because soon it's going to be
everywhere yeah
no I think I think for people that are
watching if you're an artist if you're a
writer this is an exciting time you know
and the exciting as we watch even as we
watch the AI art
you know appear as we watch the AI
writing which will probably it's
probably being used by some people
without us knowing but it's probably
it's all there 100 you know as we're as
we're watching as we're watching this I
think that it feels like as something is
being exhausted there's definitely
something else that is being born and we
can get an inkling of that in in the
things that uh
and Nicholas is is bringing up so uh
yeah so it's it's an exciting time
artists get to it you know we need to we
we have there are better stories and we
need to tell them and very images we
need to make them
yeah but you know for us artists it's
not as easy as just simply sitting down
and doing the thing like there's there's
there's things we have to do with
ourselves
um that that need to make it that will
make it possible for us to tell those
stories it's not simply okay now I have
to do this I'm going to sit down and I'm
going to create this thing we have to
form ourselves we have to there there
are certain things that we have to do
um very intensely to our imaginations
and to our uh internal fragment itself
because we are fragmented too we have to
work on that internal wholeness uh not
in both a spiritual sense but also in an
artistic sense
um you know we we need to we need to
have occasional fasts from visual
culture we need to like stop watching
stuff all the time on our phones and on
our like seriously yeah because we're
saturated there's no space in which we
can we can allow for you know the
richness of our imagination which is so
good at connecting things outside of
what it sees
we need to like fill ourselves with
beauty in all different forms you know
if you're a writer go and listen to some
music right uh if you're if you're a
visual artist go read something that's
that's outside of your normal
um uh palette right immerse yourself in
beauty in all different kinds of things
but also limit limit how much you're it
you are infusing your eyes with the
garbage because there's so much out
there yeah
all right Nicholas so so tell people
where they can find your stuff where
they can find your novels you're also
doing podcasts uh yeah let them know I'm
doing too much yes it's true I I should
apply my uh what I just said to myself
and cut out half the things I do just
just to allow space for
for internal wholeness but you know I'm
working on it yeah everything you can
find everything on my website
nicholascotard.com including uh the the
new Novella that we talked about which
is free uh it's on it's not for sale
anywhere this is a an experimental thing
I'm doing I'm giving it out in ebook
format for free to anyone who signs up
to my uh newsletter which you can do on
the front page of my website so go and
get it so go check it out and and for
those who don't know Nicholas and I are
also we've also started working together
more explicitly and so we are uh we're
we're working towards the Snow White
story that I've mentioned a few times
and in the hopes of maybe moving towards
some really great uh fairy tales in the
future Nicholas is also an expert on
fairy tales he has a a wonderful podcast
on Russian fairy tales that you can
check out from his website as well and
so there's going to be a lot of exciting
stuff in the future uh you'll hear more
from Nicholas and myself on all that
very soon so thanks everybody